it was like calm like a ghost I saw its
eyes shining white eyes and it goes down
underground
the strange things going on all over the
city people behind this are not like you
and me
there's a hidden society it goes back
centuries
yesterday wizard entered New York with a
case
a case full of magical creatures and
unfortunately some have escaped tini
he brought men home that's mr. Scamander
he's lost something I'm going to help
him find we're gonna recapture my
creatures that's what I get hurt they're
currently in alien terrain surrounded by
millions of the most vicious creatures
on the planet humans
magical beasts I'll terrorize and no
manages when no matches are afraid they
attack contain this little mean boar
it's on but why would I have to wear
something like this because your skull
is acceptable to breakage under immense
force
don't panic that there's absolutely
nothing to worry about
I want to be a wizard there is a
stranger who comes to this village from
the sea he comes in the winter when
people are hungry brings fish comes on
the King tide I was last night
took I believe that an enemy is coming
from far away I'm looking for warriors
this stranger others like him
I'm building an alliance to defend us
it's very important that I see this man
Barry Allen Bruce Wayne you said that
like it explains why there's a total
stranger sitting in the dark in my
second favorite chair
he said he'll fight with us or what more
more and more or less
probably more or less he said no he said
no [ __ ] man I don't know who you are but
whoever you're looking for
so you're fast that feels like an
oversimplification I'm putting together
a team people with special abilities see
I believe enemies are coming stop right
there I'm in you are just like that yeah
I need friends right guys heat this
I heard about you didn't think you were
real and realize useful
Arthur curry here you can talk to fish
tell me story tell me every detail
I woke up somewhere from a nightmare
what was it about then then mean lots to
care about business
hold up hold up backups you've left
something out
are you right in the book they all lived
happily ever after no they didn't know
that because for the first time there's
something you don't know
something nobody told you
you wanted to prophesy this is your
prophecy young man
from hunting faint I'm worried I don't
come a man you want what is that
my lord Gary I know your story behold
the man who pulled sword from stone I'm
not getting drawn into this mess there's
an army of you it's only one of me
I'll talk I'm happy to talk but there is
no way that I am fighting
so what happens now you know happens now
oh you're quickly becoming a legend Oh
now that the time masters are gone
history has been left unguarded
everything that has happened or will
happen is subject to the exploitation of
time criminals which is why history
needs new protectors it needs legends
my name is Rex Tyler I'm a member of the
Justice Society of America but we'll
pass the point of worrying about the
timeline
I need to talk to you about the legends
I think they're all in trouble
somebody just blew up New York during
World War two think we can all guess who
that someone is
Nazis hate Nazis it's not like the time
masters are here to stop her
we are history's last line of defense
relax captain we got this
I'm waiting a long time for this a long
time for what to kill you
are you uh sure you know how to fly this
thing let's find out
you men yeah
yeah I look huh
you have been my greatest love
be careful Diana
they do not deserve you
if you never met a man before but what
about your father I had no father I was
brought to life by Zeus oh that's neat
I cannot give you this
what I do is not up to you
it's Etta candy I'm Steve Trevor's
secretary what is a secretary I go where
he tells me to go and I do what you
tells me to do
yeah where I'm from that's called
slavery I really like her
fantastic ladies after you do are you
Mike
nice
here's to honor among thieves we almost
pulled it off
my friends are eating steak it's low
despite what everybody thought wait for
them to ask you
they're gonna blame us for the whole
thing where the patsies
don't forget mmm we're the bad guys
please don't make any sense
you don't know that we've all heard the
stories of Samson leveling a temple with
a single push for the Philistine weapon
of mass destruction named Goliath
the next war will be fought with these
metahumans vido ours or theirs
I want a simple task force of the most
dangerous people on the planet okay no
stand down made up away
y'all Joker's must be crazy this is the
deal you're going somewhere very bad
look at the pretty light to do something
that gets killed you might want to work
on your team motivation thing you heard
of Phil Jackson yeah he's like the gold
standard ok triangle [ __ ]
I hate the farm like hey lookie here oh
yeah
I can't wait to show you my toys we're
going to the swirling ring of trash in
the sky they walk in the park
easy peasy don't make me shoot you
biggest Boston I've been a trellis
I'm a bigger problem when I spray
I've just begun yeah so when kids
catching my back but she can't fathom my
chair
forgive me for my wrongs I have just
begun no mercy ain't no mercy you